like in 2016 90 000 bitcoin or 120 000
something like that uh was stolen from
bit of finnex so at this time in 2016
that was worth 70 million
and then fast forward whatever it's been
five years and
it
that amount of bitcoin is worth 3.6
billion dollars so the people that stole
it were this couple
[Music]
and they tried to launder launder it i
guess through like a series of crypto
transactions and uh the feds ended up
tracing them it's like the biggest
financial seizure of all time he was a
yc founder i think he started some
company and they and he went through yc
and she
is like a
self-proclaimed like comedy rapper so
this is her right here
razzle con is her rap name
you can't get as high
i would kidnap her
what the [ __ ]
i mean for the bitcoin that wasn't the
core of the bitcoin no one was no one
asked that no one
oh and back to noelle's question yeah i
guess i would um
see this is where the brain doesn't make
the connection is that we were talking
about it before recording no we were not
without kidnapping we weren't talking
about committing the act of kidnapping
but i i read a headline about crypto
people getting kidnapped
for ransom oh yes yes in my brain i made
the connection i would kidnap her that's
all that came out so how would you
kidnap her
i mean
it would that's a good question
uh because i i used to ponder how i
would rob a bank
how would you it's so easy how would i
rob a bank you would have to okay
you would
oh god
how i would rob a bank is i would wait
until the the bank is opening and i
would go up in like a trench coat and i
would have a fake bomb strap to me and i
would act terrified i would act
terrified and just say you know
something along the lines of please you
know they have my son or something and
you've got to give me
as much money
as you can
in this bag and please do don't call the
police or something you know
really ham it up right and then they
give you the money and you you just jump
over the wall or whatever i don't think
that's ever gonna work oh [ __ ] you
you're right yeah sorry that was that
was it's really intense it's it can be
so much easier
how would you do it
so but couldn't you just say like hey
give me money or else i'm just going to
blow this [ __ ] up
like why would you that's it
for the sun being kept so that they
would feel like oh man i'm definitely
not going to call the cops after this oh
because if if i do i'm definitely
hitting the button
wait how in fact the button doesn't work
is that true yeah why well i used to
work at a bank it depends
huh so the button
it does work but it it's like it takes a
while so it's not reliable
i'm just telling you yeah hear that
robbers
highly unethical
the bulletproof glass ain't bulletproof
either the the most common way is that
people commit petty theft because for
most banks
it's a write-off
to like rob a teller because at any
given time they don't really have that
much money on them they keep it locked
away
so most people do is they come in and
they just they slip a note
to the teller and they say
give me everything your drawer or i'm
gonna do this or i have a gun you need
to give me and and tellers are
instructed to just do it and then that's
the end is that what you so is that how
you would do it you would slip it well
yeah i think the most genius part though
is some guy
uh
he got he got away with multiple like
like robberies at different branches one
branch two times like
back to back and he put a [ __ ]
band-aid on his nose and whenever the
police came and asked for a description
the only thing that people could
remember was the [ __ ] band-aid that's
so smart yeah [ __ ] you see
crypto
ruined the [ __ ] world because before
thieves used to be [ __ ] cool yeah
it's like you had to walk into a bank
and and like threaten people
for real and go to a safe and fill a bag
and there was jump in a truck now
thieves are [ __ ] razzmatazz or
whatever yeah literally yeah like come
on yeah some guy with a cartoon profile
picture is just taunting you being like
a heavenly father i took all your
examples
i have your apes
i have stolen your apes yeah and i just
have to wait my apes are gone right i
have to watch some guy cry about losing
his son's tuition it's just like not
yeah yeah the branch i worked at um they
got they had to put in bulletproof glass
because it got robbed and the way it got
robbed is two guys ran up in there with
a [ __ ] mp5 that's sick that's a big
gun right i mean it's just it's like
it's just like a 22 caliber
but it's just like it's a
pretty dumb gun
they just [ __ ] they ran in and hopped
over the counter like straight out of a
movie and just like held that [ __ ] up it
was like
give it all to me
damn it's cold yeah that's badass yeah
now it's [ __ ] eight boys
you were taking it from a bank which
everyone hates yeah now you're taking it
from some random guy
who got in over his head on crypto yeah
not as fun no
well
now now that money just goes to the
government and then what
it's like they're going to give it back
to right no i think they are actually i
read they're trying to figure out the
best way to get in contact with um but
maybe that's extremely naive of me
the the doj just being like um we're
figuring out a way for you guys to get
your bitcoin we're definitely going to
give it back
as they're like buying apes yeah
no that one's sick with the glasses by
that one yeah this shit's going to go up
yeah
no you want to get an animated one that
shit's gonna be big yeah they uh that
actually
because it was only worth what what did
you say 60 million 70 million so those
people would not only be made whole but
they would be rich rich yes yeah
damn these robbers i wonder if the
government is going to do the right
thing but do you get do you get
prosecuted for stealing 70 million
there's like that has to that's like
sentencing different right
i don't know it's not their fault it
turned into 3.6 billion you think that's
probably their defense look we thought
we were stealing 70 million yeah
this is insane
i wanted to be a billionaire
i didn't know that much everyone said it
was going to crash we were just planning
on having you know 700
it was 70 million at the time you guys
have been laughing at these people
i do believe that the maximum sentence
is 25 years i read for whatever
financial crisis well because it was
defrauding the united states government
is one of the sentences i don't remember
how they defrauded what that means what
she's got 25 years to work on the most
fire rap album of 2020 2047. wow
dude damn dude what the [ __ ]
damn damn human calculator it's 25 22.
yeah but give me a second
[ __ ] nerd
yeah okay right yeah what a dog i'm
supposed to be the math guy
22 plus 25 yeah you carry the one
you're him you sound just like him
this is ridiculous yeah yeah now who's
getting laughed at it's supposed to be a
good joke best
album of 2020 2047. it's still good it's
still good what's her name rez rex what
was it
razzle con
can we
i want to listen to some more razzles i
wish we had that video of her giving
business advice click on one of her tech
talks um she had a lot of tick tocks
it's insane i want to see that pancake
one i want to see i want to see
i really like her she's truly psychotic
why she's probably look she's got brain
worms from having that much money she's
just like hus doesn't get it
on social media and how [ __ ]
superficial and consumers oh my god
why don't you try a pancake and that's
it
whoa
whoa
this might be worth it
these are famous pancakes whoa
i can't believe it this is [ __ ] reels
right these rules
this is like really cool this is my
comment on social media and how it's
really superficial i love how her
husband was just like shut up try the
[ __ ] pancakes i've been sitting here
waiting you don't have to
give commentary we're worth three
billion dollars is this like a movie
like they're gonna there's some
hollywood
they've already read about the books
it's gonna be an incredible book
yeah play another one
this is no i'm like truly just
transfixed i think if you go to the
there's a yes that one that's an air pal
airpod wrap that we can enjoy probably
great hair
you know
oh yeah that's airpods [ __ ]
airpods where are my goddamn airpods
apple find my phone but it won't work at
home yeah we're good she she's it's like
she's trying to be grimes
like some kind of really really really
shitty grimes yeah i'm just blown away
that
that when they ordered those i don't
know those teflon pancakes
and
the waiter came over and said they're
like
look at these dorks
not knowing
that they were billionaires yeah truly
why didn't they start selling it all
that's kind of that's kind of a bad
thing when you have a billion dollars
and people don't
you know like to be a billionaire
i don't know i think it requires you to
be a certain type of person and the fact
that like they have a billion dollars
and no one could sniff that out of them
yeah right you should be able to tell
yeah it's kind of a bad like
you should give the money away honestly
but wouldn't that be a horrible feeling
like knowing you have
three billion dollars but not being able
to spend it because yes you have to
figure out how to launder it and not get
arrested and it's just sitting there in
an account that's why you're not a true
billionaire true billionaire would have
figured that out alone you find some
patsies yeah right
why couldn't they just start selling it
though
slowly who knows because
what are you going to put on your your
tax form oh my gosh we'll get wrapped up
in taxes we're talking about people we
can get a we can get a tax guy yeah
yeah i guess you need a lawn like you
need a business
how would you launder it what would you
do a strip club baby tony soprano style
there we go the bada-bing you know what
i do but
parking lots
ooh frankie muniz style yeah that's what
he did he owns a ton of parking lots in
los angeles he does yes no way i
remember learning that
years ago and i was like god damn that's
smart you know he doesn't remember any
of malcolm in the middle that's what he
says
what it's not true
you know
he says not that that's what everyone
says oh he does remember so i'm just
another victim of the internet yeah but
you and me both pal i liked thinking
about him and brian cranston meeting up
and brian being like yeah and you had
the thing on your head and it was
oh that sounds really great but
sorry